لذلك أنا آخذ مرحبًا بالجميع ، اسمي
ليل صالح وقبل أن تشعر بالأسف
وقبل أن يبدأ عقلك في الشرود
بعيدًا ، دعني أفكر في شيء واحد فقط
لم أذهب إلى الفضاء ولكنني واجهت
شيئًا يمكنك قوله أخذني إليه
عالم آخر أود أن أخبرك به قليلاً
عن نفسي ، فأنا ما تسميه
المفتاح المطلق كما هو الحال في أنا في حالة حب مع
نوع الخيال العلمي لأظهر لك مدى
هوسي ، وهنا بعض من
أفلامي المفضلة  كتب البرامج التلفزيونية
وألعاب الفيديو وحتى تطبيقات iPhone ، يمكن لأي شخص أن
يخمن ما هو مشترك بينها جميعًا ، وأنا
أعلم أنه سؤال صعب ، لذا دعني
أخبرك فقط بالفضاء الخارجي ، ألا
يدهشك فقط عدد الأشياء غير المكتشفة
الموجودة هناك على جميع
الكواكب  كل المجرات ، جميع الأنظمة الشمسية
، وربما حتى احتمال وجود
كائنات فضائية ، حسنًا ، ربما أكون
بعيدًا جدًا ، لذا دعني أعود إلى المسار الصحيح ،
بدأت تجربتي السحرية بأكملها
صدق أو لا تصدق بإخطار بريد إلكتروني
لا أعرف عنه  أنت ولكن
عادة عندما أحصل على م  من المدرسة
، تجاهلت ذلك تلقائيًا ، لكن شيئًا ما
حول هذا لفت انتباهي
الموضوع قرأ أكاديمية ناسا للفضاء التي كنت
مفتونًا بها لأننا سنقوم أخيرًا
بدراسة أسرار
الكون ، فتحت البريد الإلكتروني وتفاقمت حماسي بشكل
كبير وقد تم ترشيحي للمتابعة
رحلة لزيارة أكاديمية ناسا للفضاء ،
قمت بمسح البريد الإلكتروني بسرعة
وببطء بدأت
حماسي في إفراغ الرحلة لمدة أسبوع في
سنغافورة ، جررت آمالي
وأحلامي وأفرغتها في سلة المهملات في
الأيام القليلة التالية التي جعلتني في حالة  من
الاكتئاب ، ظل عقلي
يتجول مرة أخرى في كل الاحتمالات ، كل
التجارب التي سأحصل عليها من الذهاب في هذه
الرحلة ، لكن الحواجز نفسها ظلت تمنع
درب أفكاري ، ربما لديك
هذه العبارات القادمة التي حفظت
هيرمان بونيه ، لماذا لا أكون زعفران شقي أبدًا
ولكن  لم يكن هذا شيئًا فقط
، لقد كان شيئًا أحببته ، كانت هذه فرصة لا
تتكرر إلا مرة واحدة في العمر ، لذلك كنت أعرف
ما إذا كنت سأقترب من هذا الأمر ، كان علي أن
أجرب  طريقة جديدة
بدأت في العصف الذهني ، لقد توصلت إلى
قائمة بجميع الإيجابيات والسلبيات التي جمعت منها
المعلومات التي عملت بجد أكثر من أي وقت
مضى في أي تقرير مدرسي أو مشروع لمدة
أسبوعين طويلين ، قدمت ببطء
الفكرة إلى عائلتي وأستمع إلى ما قاموا به
يجب أن أقول وحاولت دمج
طريقة لعمل ما يريدون في
هدفي الرئيسي وأخيراً حصلت على
موافقتهم كنت ذاهبًا إلى سنغافورة مع
أختي بالطبع واجهت العديد من المصاعب
والعقبات أثناء وجودي هناك ولكن لا شيء
لم أستطع تحملها ، اتخذت
الخطوة الأولى وهي أصعب خطوة ، ومن هناك فصاعدًا ،
أصبح الأمر أسهل في البداية ،
شعرت بالحنين إلى الوطن ، فقد كنت خائفًا من
عدم معرفة أي شخص هناك وكنت
أيضًا خجولًا جدًا للتواصل الاجتماعي  مع
بقية الطلاب في الأكاديمية ، ولكن
مع بدء الدورة ، لم أشعر أبدًا بأنني
في المنزل الآن إذا بدأت أتحدث عن
كل شيء ، كل
شيء فعلته في ذلك الأسبوع ، سأستمر في الحديث
لساعات ولن أفعل  لا مانع من القيام بذلك
ولكن بلدي  الوقت هنا محدود ، لذا دعني
أقدم لك ملخصًا موجزًا كان لدينا نش
طان في لعبة Paintball حيث اس
عدنا جميعًا لبعضنا البعض ، حا
لنا قيادة طائرة بدون طي
ر ومركبة جوية بدون طيار وحاول قيادة Martian Rover
نموذجًا أوليًا من Martian Rover
منذ البداية  تأخر أحدهم لمدة أربع ساعات
مما يعني إرسال المسبار إلى
الفضاء لإرسال رسالة إلى روفرز في
الفضاء في انتظار ساعات حتى تتحرك
دون معرفة محيطها ،
لقد حاولنا بناء صاروخنا الذي يعمل بالطاقة المائية
والذي حلّق على ارتفاع 75 قدمًا
75  قدم
75 مترًا ، هل تعلم كم يبلغ ارتفاع
هذا المبنى ثلاثة أضعاف هذا المبنى ، فقد أجرينا
أيضًا نقاشًا مع الطلاب من
سنغافورة حول ملكية
الفضاء ورأينا كيف كانت آرائنا
مختلفة تمامًا عن آرائهم ، ثم
أجرينا تجربة نقلنا الصوت  من
خلال الليزر من خلال أشعة الليزر وكان لدينا
أيضًا مهمة إنقاذ حيث كان علينا
إنقاذ زملائنا في الفريق من درجات
الحرارة المنخفضة ، وأخيراً حضرنا
دورة فيزياء في واحدة من  أفضل
المدارس في سنغافورة ورأينا كيف
اختلفت بيئتنا التعليمية عن
بيئتها في الأيام القليلة الماضية من هذه
الرحلة كانت ضبابية حيث كان هناك الكثير مما كان
يحدث حتى أنني لم أستطع حتى تسجيل
الوصول مع أمي وأنا أعلم ذلك  قد لا
يبدو هذا شيئًا كبيرًا بالنسبة لكم جميعًا ،
لكن والديّ هما
ما تسميهما مفرطًا في الحماية ، لذا فقد
تعلمت أشياء كثيرة في تلك الرحلة
بالإضافة إلى الاستمتاع بتعليمي
على Science Space.
الانفتاح على
أشخاص جدد على مستوى مختلف وهو مستوى
لا يمكنك تحقيقه دون الذهاب في
رحلة معهم وتعلمت كيفية
التعامل مع المواقف بشكل مستقل ،
وأخيراً فتحت لي تعرفت على
ثقافات جديدة وأنماط حياة جديدة
أعطتني  نظرة مختلفة للعالم الذي
تخرجت فيه من الأكاديمية ،
لا ، لقد تخرجت من أكاديمية ناسا للفضاء
وأعتقد أنني كنت
سأفقد ذلك في كل ذلك إذا
لم أتخذ هذه الخطوة الأولى ، فإن الخطوة
التي لم تفتح فقط  هذه
الفرص بالنسبة لي ولكن أيضًا
للأقارب الآخرين لأصدقاء آخرين
للفتيات الإماراتيات الشابات الأخريات لاتخاذ خطواتهن الأولى
كما قال نيل
أرمسترونج ، أول رجل يطأ قدمه على
سطح القمر ، خطوة صغيرة للرجل
وقفزة عملاقة من أجل  بشرية على
متن باخرة في شيكاغو أمر بذبح ابتسامة